seulement 10 m c'est la marge d'erreur
de localisation des bus skibus a
aujourd'hui son nouveau système d'aide à
l'exploitation et à l'information
voyageur le SAE IV il était temps et
mais ça s'inscrit aussi dans la dans la
dans la durée normale d'un tel projet je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut être fier
de de ce dispositif restera plus
prochainement à le connecter au au
smartphone par exemple ce système permet
d'envoyer une information au clients en
temps réel au niveau de Born qui sont
plter soit sous les abris soit hors des
abris sur des poteaux et il y a 154
bornes qui sont disséminées sur le
territoire de 50 ans les bornes
annoncent l'heure du prochain passage ou
un retard en cas de perturbation ce
nouveau système a nécessité plus de 3
millions d'euros entièrement financé par
le STIF les transports sont un sont un
enjeu majeur pour la région puisque les
la région a considérablement augmenté de
6 % donc le budget donc dévoé au
transport dédicacé au transport que les
transports en commun sont aussi une
parmi les priorités puisqu'ils
contribuent à la réduction de la de la
pollution et à la préservation de la
qualité de l'air je pense que c'est
aussi important de de le rappeler on a
aujourd'hui SEP gares sur le territoire
il faut en profiter c'est un atout on a
effectivement beaucoup d'entreprises
hein je vous rappelle 235000 habitants
145000 emplois et bien il faut aussi que
on soit plus pertinent dans l'approche
et pour que les personnes qui viennent
travailler chez nous aussi puissent
avoir les Meille
skibus a aujourd'hui 171 véhicules
équipés chaque année plus de 8 millions
d'usagers emprunte le réseau
cantinois